le suspense est insoutenable et le
verdict est dramatique
hélas tu management selon cette horloge
disons alimentaire est symbolique il ne
reste que deux minutes avant la fin du
monde
la pire menace un tremblement de terre
non soumis non plus monstres de l'espace
que même superman ne peut terrasser pas
du tout beaucoup plus menaçant que les
pires films catastrophe hollywoodien
selon les scientifiques qui ont mis au
point l'horloge de l'apocalypse c'est la
dure réalité du monde actuel john pitney
streicher nous prépare survivent d'abord
il ya la menace nucléaire ravivées par
donald trump et par son ennemi juré kim
jong-un y multiplie ses essais
provocateur ensuite il ya les
changements climatiques qui bouleverse
la planète
sans oublier la montée des nationalismes
un peu partout dans le monde
il est donc 23h58 mais d'où vient cette
horloge de l'apocalypse la première
parution c'est en 1947
c'est dans le bulletin du scientifique
de l'atome et le butin qui sait depuis
quelques années en 1947 dans le prix la
décision de représenter graphiquement la
menace que représentait le père inutile
il faut dire que la bombe atomique
lancée sur hiroshima en 1945 avait
changé la donne
la pire année avant 2018 c'était en 1953
lors des tests de bombes
thermonucléaires il était minuit moins
de la meilleure c'était 1991 lorsque
bush et gorbatchev ont signé le traité
de réduction des armes
il était alors 23h43 2018 est avec 1953
donc l'année la plus dangereuse depuis
la création de l'horloge ce que veut
faire cette horloge c'est bien dire aux
gens on est sur le bord de la
catastrophe mais en même temps ce ne
sont pas des prophètes non plus donc
l'objectif n'est pas de dire on arrive à
minuit mais c'est d'être capable
d'évaluer en fait la menace que pèse à
la fois le père et nucléaires puis aussi
l'environnement de quelques années il
reste deux minutes avant la fin du monde
vous fait quoi
je pars chez mes parents je vais leur
dire
je l'âme je les aime chat passé ce temps
avec les gens que j'aime vraiment ce que
de quoi redonner foi en l'humanité et
vous que feriez vous je vous donne deux
minutes pour y penser
pas plus frédéric arnould radio canada
montréal